few farmers can remember a harvest as
dry and dusty as this it's an anxious
time not just because harvesting on
flinty soil can bring the risk of sparks
and fire
this drought is already impacting yields
of certain crops and adding extra costs
to feeding livestock
so after months of dry weather and now
the really hot temperature you you can
see the grass is brown there's no food
left out for the animals in the field so
we're having to feed
next year next winter's food already but
many farmers are now prevented from
accessing the water they desperately
need now that drought has been declared
in many regions
given the future being mapped out for us
by climate change it's time for action
they argue we have enough water in this
country it's normally in the west and in
the winter and we need investment in
infrastructure to have it in the right
place at the right time so there's
enough water for people food and the
environment this will not be the last
drought the government need to address
this they are the ones have the overall
control the environment agency clearly
have a major role to play but government
need to lead
today the labour party have called for
an urgent cobra meeting in response to
the crisis
and called for the publication of the
national resilience strategy almost a
year after the consultation closed it's
hard to overestimate the impact this
drought could have if it does drive up
food prices at a time of high inflation
and a cost of living crisis but without
enough water to go around prioritizing
it for agriculture comes at a direct
cost to our environment
and that isn't the only concern this
weekend's high temperatures have bought
more fires this is bag shot in surrey
and it's emerged that despite widespread
warnings about their use this fire in
studland dorset yesterday was caused by
a barbecue according to the local fire
service i don't think i've ever seen the
conditions be so perfect for wildfires
that they are at the moment
we've had virtually no rain for as long
as i can remember the temperatures are
very high humidity is quite low and
we're seeing quite high wind speed so as
soon as the fire starts it will quickly
spread
and often it takes five fighters five
ten minutes before they'll arrive at the
scene of the fire so the fire will have
spread quite a long way before we get
there next week's range should rapidly
reduce fire risk but the challenge of
making britain more resilient to heat
waves and drought will take more than
just a change in the weather
tom clark sky news